[Music]
[Music]
is
these all
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is very important politically and
operationally to ensure a ship signing
of the remaining status agreements
second we will continue working with you
in the region to strengthen reception
capacities and Asylum systems the
engagement of the European Asylum
support office in the region in this
regard as you understand it is very
important as well as of course the
cooperation with international
organizations like IOM and UNH I
mentioned before our concern about the
situation in bosnia and herzegovina
earth here i would like to say that we
should avoid
by all means seeing the situation that
we saw unfold in the winter of 2015 and
2016 we still have in our minds this
very dire picture we need to make sure
that all migrants and refugees are
accommodated in reception facilities
that are fit for this purpose the
humanitarian organizations are on the
ground and stand ready to support well
but they can only do so under the
guidance and the leadership of the
Bosnian authorities mr. Magnus dear
dragon we fully understand that pressure
your country is facing this is the
reality and be sure that we are going we
shall continue showing solidarity and
support to Bosnia but I urge you to
urgently take measures to ensure that
all people stranded in your country
received proper shelter we are ready to
help as I said but your government also
needs
pluck'd third we need to give priority
and strengthen our efforts in returns
return of third country nationals
who do not have the right to stay is a
very important step in fighting
irregular migration the readmission of
your own is going well and return rates
have remained high eager member states
deem cooperation and return to be
excellent but in order to relieve the
pressure from your territories I would
encourage you all step up our efforts to
complete your own bilateral readmission
agreements with third countries of
origin transit such as Pakistan
Afghanistan Iran Iraq Turkey Tunisia
Morocco Algeria and Bangladesh in the
meantime you should continue to carry
out voluntary returns I know that IOM is
already assisting you operation fourth I
would like to reiterate that your visa
policies need to be aligned with the EU
a key in order to prevent entry and
abuse by Nationals of high-risk
countries
let's also this the issue of citizenship
by investment problems which can pose
risks risks in terms of security money
laundering tax evasion terrorist
financing corruption we will continue
monitoring all these developments in the
framework of the visa suspension
mechanism report fifth the fight against
migrant smuggling needs to be set up as
a part of our joint response we keep on
seeing tragic stories in the news when
smugglers employ a very dangerous modus
operandi which puts the lives of
migrants in danger due to overcrowding
in concede lorries advance
or fried trains we need to work together
and use available tools including
provided by Europol and its European
migrants Martin Center to fight these
serious crimes to conclude we all need
to move ahead to move forward by doing
more efforts on all these fronts I know
we all have the same aim we have proven
that we are stronger when we work
together and I would like to reiterate
once again that you all have our full
support cooperation politically and
financially in order to achieve our
common goals let's continue in this vein
thank you very much for attention thank
you